[Music]
on the evening of may 6 2014 a woman in
her late 70s exited la che hospital in
nice south of france her name helene
pastor the richest woman in monaco
helene was a senior surviving member of
what is in effect monaco's second
dynasty and it had been a bad year for
monaco's richest woman but little did
she know it was about to get much worse
two years earlier her only daughter was
diagnosed with breast cancer then this
year her brother michael died leaving
her as the last heir to the pastor
dynasty and now her only son 47 year old
gildo has suffered a stroke that left
him partially paralyzed unable to speak
and hospitalized for the last four
months and every day without fail she
made the 45 minute trip from her home in
monaco to the hospital to visit her son
gildo by his bedside this left monaco's
princess as helene was nicknamed often
wondering if there is a god end quote
despite the bad luck she was having that
day helene received some good news after
almost four months in the hospital gilda
would be coming home soon so she makes
her way to the hospital as usual she
arrived at la shea hospital that tuesday
afternoon driven by her longtime
chauffeur 64 year old muhammad darwich a
few hours later at 7 pm she left the
hospital and made her way back to where
her driver was waiting she got back to
her black lancia voyager and got in the
front seat her white pyramiding shepard
bell took up most of the back seat her
driver started the car it slowly rolled
forward as the street ahead was crowded
with traffic and pedestrians but in the
shadows a young man was lurking watching
the car very carefully helene's car had
just begun to turn onto the main road
but traffic blocked them from
accelerating which made for an almost
perfect chokepoint for an attack
seizing the opportunity the stalker
jumps out wielding a sawed-off shotgun
he aimed at the front passenger seat
window and with the squeeze of the
trigger fired
twice lead and broken glass flew
everywhere blood splattered the interior
of the car helene and her driver were
hit in the face neck chest and abdomen
her driver's foot slams on the gas and
hits the vehicle in front of it and just
as suddenly as the shooter appeared he
vanished
a clean hit
or so he thought
doctors sworn the vehicle as helene
pastor and mohammedar which late slumped
over in the car covered in blood
miraculously they were both still
breathing both helene and her driver
were taken back to the hospital for
treatments four days later her driver
dies leaving helene as a sole witness of
the crime she seemed to be recovering
well and her doctors didn't fear for her
life she had even been cooperating with
police but then 15 days after the
shooting helene pastor was pronounced
dead at dawn on may 21 2014
what proceeded was one of the most high
profile murder investigations in
european history the richest woman in
monaco that lived a quiet life in one of
the safest cities in the world gunned
down in front of a busy hospital could
it be a mafia hit a business deal gone
wrong a disgruntled family member that
didn't inherit any of the dynasty or was
it something far more sinister whatever
it was it would shake monaco to its core
murder
the assassination of monaco's richest
woman
[Music]
the ultra wealthy like helene pastor and
everyone else that lives in monaco get
access to the best investment advisors
wealth managers and more and who does
the public like you get access to
nothing the best investments have always
been reserved for the ultra wealthy and
as they get wealthier they leave the
rest of us to fend for ourselves that
didn't sit well with some people so they
developed titan today's video sponsor
titan is like the advent of commission
free stock training apps but for hedge
funds it gives you access to an
award-winning investment team in the
palm of your hands with zero performance
fees no lockups a flat rate advisory fee
and record-breaking returns titan
already manages over 750 million dollars
for over 35 000 plus clients that are
just like you all you have to do is
download the app sign up deposit just a
hundred dollars and boom you get access
to award-winning investment strategies
for us-based stocks to international
stocks to even crypto assets titan's
unique time-tested strategy of
identifying a rare species of stocks
known as compounders and holyone tights
has allowed them to outperform all the
major indices and robo advisors since
their inception it's not an etf or
mutual fund and they don't just expertly
invest your money they explain
everything by giving you court-sized
seats with real-time video updates all
it takes is a hundred dollars to get
started on your journey towards smart
investing get started today at titan.com
jake and get your first three months of
expert investment management for zero
fees that's titan.com jake for three
months free
[Music]
the dynasty
[Music]
colleen pastner was the only surviving
grandchild of john batty's pastor a poor
stone mason from italy jean patis had
arrived in the south of france to find
work as a construction worker after more
than 50 years later in 1936 some of the
buildings he worked on caught the eye of
monaco's ruling prince
he commissioned jean-baptiste to build a
football stadium and from then on there
was no looking back
jean-baptiste's son gildo started buying
up waterfront real estate in monaco
after his father died on these
properties he could show up in luxury
apartment buildings from which the
pastor family fortune was created and
because of his father's friendship with
the prince gildo and his children soon
became very close with the ruling family
when gildo pastored the first died he
left his real estate empire to his two
sons victor and michael and to his
daughter helene and by 2014 both
helene's brothers had died leaving her
as a so inheritor of a fortune worth
more than 23 billion dollars
eventually helene gave birth to her
daughter sylvia and then to her son
gildo the one that was later
hospitalized even though she was the
richest person in monaco helene kept
herself she wasn't a social butterfly
and almost never appeared at any monaco
events it seemed the only thing she
truly loved were her children and her
dog belle sylvia and gilda received an
allowance of 500 000 euros a month
at the time that was the equivalent of
610 000 us dollars a month both siblings
live close to their mother in luxury
monaco apartments
so in a nutshell helene was a quiet
woman who didn't seem to have any
enemies so who would want her dead it
was a question that baffled local
authorities
the investigation begins
[Music]
because the shooting occurred in france
not monaco then these police force were
the ones in charge of the case but as
soon as the investigation began things
went dark
helene pastor had no enemies her family
and friends could think of no one who
would want to harm her everyone in
monaco loved her and no evidence had
been left at the scene even helene
herself told police that she couldn't
think of anyone who would want her dead
but then just a month after her death
police announced they had arrested 25
people in relation to the shooting and
they claimed to have identified the
killers for a woman who seemed to be
loved by most of monaco 25 suspects was
a lot soon after the shooting four taxi
drivers came forward to share
information with the police one said he
had picked up two young men from ini's
train station that morning they had been
traveling from marseille and he had
driven them to a hotel another two taxi
drivers said they had driven one man
each to la shea hospital on the day of
the murder and finally a fourth taxi
driver said he had picked up two men at
the train station who wanted to travel
back to marseille they have been arguing
and eventually agreed to pay him 500
euros for the 100 mile trip
these two men samin syed ahmed and alhay
hamadi had criminal records but no one
knew who they were so police kept
searching eventually they arrested the
only two suspects that mattered and it
sent shockwaves through monaco
the first suspect
helene's own daughter sylvia pastor and
the second suspect was her partner of 28
years voija janoski
monaco's gatsby
[Music]
was a cambridge educated polish
businessman and sylvia passed his
partner for 28 years in 1986 he met
sylvia at a party in monaco at the time
she was married to an italian
industrialist which whom she had a
daughter but her marriage was troubled
so it wasn't surprising when she quickly
fell for the charming well-dressed
janoski soon after meeting him sylvia
moved back to monaco where she and
janosky raised her daughter everyone who
knew sylvia says she was madly in love
with janoski they never marry but they
did have a daughter together born in
1997. like her mother sylvia was quiet
and reserved but janoski was the
complete opposite he was the man of the
town a philanthropist socialite and big
spender exactly what you would expect a
rich man in monaco to be at the time of
the murder janoski was the owner of a
nanotech company and an oil business he
was also poland's honorary council to
the principality of monaco even though
he was a successful businessman janowski
seemed to have no problem spending
sylvia's money which caused many
arguments between helene and sylvia he
bought houses in london and switzerland
purchased a yacht leased on private jets
and started many businesses all with
sylvia pastor's monthly allowance and
sylvia never asked any questions she
trusted janasi completely and janowski
knew how to please the crowd his
donations to charity led him to become
the co-founder of monaco against autism
and was awarded the national order of
merit by the french president so on
paper he was a very impressive man then
in the early 2000s janosky and sylvia
made a new friend pascal duryak he was a
fitness trainer with dreams of opening
up his own gym and for more than a
decade pascal duryak was janowski's
trainer and sylvia's massour and they
became really close friends to the point
where there was very little pascal
didn't know about their lives
with this wealthy lifestyle personal
trainer and mysore included everyone in
monaco believed voice janoski was just
like any other businessman in monaco
rich powerful charming with a taste of
luxury he was respected and liked by all
of monaco's residents all except one
motive to kill
[Music]
24 hours after being arrested sylvia
passer was released and police announced
she was cooperating with the
investigation janowski however wasn't so
lucky as police dug into his past his
facade as monaco's favorite millionaire
quickly eroded instead of studying at
cambridge university janowski had
actually moved to london in 1971 where
he had a few odd jobs and eventually
worked as security for a casino instead
of a background as a businessman he was
a glorified bouncer at the famous monte
carlo casino in monaco where he walked
the casino floors to spot cheaters his
love life was filled with broken
marriage after broken marriage and as
nanotech and oil companies sylvia and
helene invested in they weren't doing
well at all unlike the facade engineered
janowski was a nobody a former employee
and definitely not even a millionaire
his impressive resume was an elaborate
lie and in 2012 the biggest essential
threat to his lavish lifestyle came
knocking sylvia was diagnosed with
breast cancer now this was a problem
because sylvia thought her husband was
wealthy logically she assumed he'd be
fine if she didn't leave him any money
after she died so she set her daughters
to be the sole inheritors of her estates
for when she died this worried janowski
most of the pastor family died young and
if sylvia passed he would have to go
back to being a pleb or he would have to
start all over finding a new rich single
woman to woo over and to make matters
worse sylvia's mother helene had never
liked janowski she despised him
according to one of the lawyers in the
case he was friends where everyone and
everyone really liked him but helene
couldn't stand him
so if sylvia died he would for sure be
left with nothing so he concocted a plan
sylvia's death from breast cancer was
looming but if she died before her
mother her lean died he would be left
with nothing
however if helene were to die first
sylvia would inherit her mom's billions
and then he would have a little bit more
time to figure out how to transfer those
billions to him when sylvia's time would
eventually come
so an assassination was concocted a very
amateur assassination but an
assassination nonetheless
[Music]
the prisoner's dilemma
[Music]
so wojciech janowski was hauled into
questioning all the police wanted to
know is if he knew anything about the
murder but at first he was being
difficult and wouldn't answer any
questions which didn't inspire any
confidence in the police that he was
innocent but just after four days of
sleeping in a cell he started to open up
janowski admitted that he knew there was
going to be a shooting on his
mother-in-law but didn't have enough
information to tip off the police why
you would not tip off the police or your
own mother-in-law about a potential
assassination if you cared about her is
beyond me and the police didn't buy it
and little did janowski know a few doors
down in another interrogation room
another arrestee was telling a different
story pascal duryak janowski's close
friend and personal trainer that we
briefly mentioned earlier pascal
confessed that it was them that plotted
the murder and it was always about the
money here's how it went down
[Music]
the assassination
[Music]
soon after sylvia was diagnosed with
breast cancer janowski asked pascal to
get him a gun he said he wanted to solve
the problem of his mother-in-law helene
but instead of getting the gun as he was
asked pascal said he would handle it at
the time investigators discovered that
janowski's bank accounts were overdrawn
by 1.2 million dollars janowski was in
desperate waters to say the least so
pascal and him started stalking helene's
every move
soon after they found out that every day
without fail she made that 45 minute
trip to the hospital and needs to visit
her son a perfect pattern to set up a
hits
but for a man with access to so much
money power and influence janowski was
no criminal mastermind he put pascal in
charge of arranging the hits so pascal
told his girlfriend about the plan his
girlfriend went to her brother to see if
he knew anyone and finally pascal was
introduced to two men sameen and alhair
they were offered the contract to kill
helene pastor for a hundred thousand
euros and another forty thousand euros
if they could also take out the driver
their hope was that if they could make
it look like the driver was the main
target and helene was just collateral it
would drive attention away from them so
i mean and alhair accepted
the day had arrived and the two
assassins left the city of marseille and
took a train to nice which is where
rookie mistake number one came in they
bought the train tickets in their names
while not knowing that all french train
stations were heavily monitored with
cameras they checked into a hotel and
made working mistake number two they
took a shower and left behind a bottle
of shower gel police were later able to
extract one of the men's dna from the
bottle after they were all squeaky clean
they traveled separately to the hospital
to stake out the location but they only
wore baseball caps and no mess samine
was the shooter i'll hair the lookout
helene inner driver pulls up near them
semen attacks and then the two men made
their escape on foots eventually taking
a taxi back to marseilles
[Music]
[Applause]
the final confession
[Music]
but this truth didn't come out easy all
in all it took an entire four years
after the assassination of a lean pastor
for janowski to finally confess to the
crime on his final day in court a crime
janowski admitted to everything that he
arranged to have his mother-in-law
killed for the inheritance money that
all the businesses that helene's money
was poured into were frauds and that his
only objection was that he never ordered
the death of the driver mohammed darwich
in the end janowski was sentenced to
life in prison pascal duryak was
sentenced to 30 years and sameen and
alhair both got life sentences
[Applause]
[Applause]
where are they now
after the sentencing of janowski gildo
pastor helene sunda was hospitalized
resettled in new york with his wife and
children sylvia on the other hand
helene's daughter and janowski's partner
has pretty much disappeared no one knows
much about where she is or what she's
doing reports say that she has broken
off all contact with janowski and
janowski he lost everything he even had
to hand over his last possession a patek
philippe watch to his lawyers to pay for
their services he is currently spending
his life sentence in leboomitz prison
one of the toughest in france
to the resonance of monaco the killing
of helene pastor turned out to be what
the french call a crime krepolu or a
crime that sparked by a motive as old as
monaco itself money
[Music]